i'll give you an example of that this is
one we were talking about uh in a
meeting this morning okay and i had them
lay it up here because when it first
came up i went ooh
that's gross i don't do that because it
sounded it could be really it could be
really wrong if it was tone deaf okay so
people are at home they got time on
their hands you know what a lot of
people are doing they're cleaning
you know a lot of people doing they're
organizing you know a lot of people are
doing uh they're cleaning out their
closets their desks their files you know
what else they're doing they're getting
their financial stuff in order right
because they've got a little time
they're doing things in every time so
they're doing stuff like doing a will
okay and they're doing stuff like
getting their term insurance in place
and they're doing stuff but if you say
hey go get a will yeah now's a good time
well everybody's freaking out that
everybody's going to die right you know
and go to mama bear go to go to mamapara
legalforms.com and get a will go to
daveramsey.com will and we'll help you
with your will
yeah yeah and when they brought that up
this morning i went oh no we can't do
that but yeah but the whole thing is a
lot of people are actually working on
that right and uh that's a reality and
i'm getting questions from people that
go you know not only have i got some
time on my hands but
and i'm not really being trying to
freaking out i'm not panicking i don't
think i'm going to die but with all this
stuff going on that's so serious it made
me stop and just be really reflective
and thoughtful about making sure i have
life insurance and making sure i have my
will in place so they are getting in
touch with zander insurance and they're
a little bit worried that coronavirus
may change some of the life insurance
pricing and that's probably a valid
worry so getting your life insurance
locked in right now but pricing before
that may go up we may see an increase on
it not sure
uh it's harder to get life insurance
right this second because the medical
nobody's working in the medical field
right on life insurance exams so it's a
little more difficult it's it's
cumbersome uh but a lot of people are
doing them you know going
todayramsey.com will there it is i'll go
and put it out there
this lady says i don't want to live in
fear but during this time the reality is
my husband and i need to get our wheels
updated we have a son that has special
needs and we want to make sure he's
cared for and uh with time on my hands
on the coronavirus wake up call i want
to get this done can you
i'm not freaking out but can you tell me
how my
do my will right and there's nothing
different that you need to do with your
will because of the pandemic doesn't
change anything
everybody should have a will regardless
of a pandemic or not right and it's not
but boy you could put that out there and
have one little twist in it and it
sounds manipulative
uh taking advantage of the fear in the
market and it's really quite the
opposite
but i don't want to stop we've always
had mama bear legal forms uh you know
for wills and i don't want to stop
offering that uh but boy you got to be
thoughtful about your messaging and your
your your ad copy so to speak in this
case so um yeah so you can get the
guardian set up you can get special
needs trust laura for your situation
with your special needs child uh putting
special needs trust that happens upon
death of both parents
only is the only time only kind you need
and then unless you're divorced uh and
you know having that having that be part
of a standard will is not that big a
deal and you can do that easily just go
to daveramsey.com and we'll help you get
slash will and we'll help you get that
lined up and you know do the same thing
go to xanderinsurance.com and get a
quote on your insurance sanders
operating from home too so they're not
answering phone calls
it's fast and they're not able to get
stuff through as fast churchill
mortgages still doing mortgages interest
rates are down yeah it's a good time to
do a mortgage but they're working from
home yeah and they're not answering
phone calls as fast but a lot of people
are looking at sitting at home going
well while we're sitting here we might
as well get this refinance going yeah
they need help so you want to provide
the service that they're needing help
with the demand is still there the felt
need is still in the marketplace you
just want to be sensitive and how you
reach them yeah yeah it's uh
i it it's very interesting so i think
your point about being
careful not to be tone deaf is is really
really important and even when you're
careful about it be be aware that
somebody's still gonna be pissed off for
sure someone's gonna be mad that you're
toddler
dave ramsey's just greedy and he's dave
ramsey's satan's son and he just wants
all your money and all this bs you know
all that stuff comes out right and so um
that's just part of it and the more
volume you do the more idiots you run
into so
uh you're going to get the more chance
of that kind of stuff happening in
showing up um
and so yeah we still see some of that
i'm apparently because we're down here
trying to do the show and make sure
everybody's helped and stays calm and uh
keep revenue so all these families that
these thousand families get to keep
their jobs and all that kind of stuff
but but we're you know we're evil
because we're down here doing the show
so i mean some of you people are just
you really really really really really
really need to understand that out of
the abundance of the heart the mouth
speaks and sometimes when you speak it
reveals a really dark place in your
heart some of you guys are out of
control out there so
be careful